Gây An sẽ có tên nhiều thị trận được thành lập, sau khi sắp nhập.
Tại vì con quân quân sẽ thành lập thị trận chá Lan, trên các sử nhập một phần sẽ tích tự nhiên của sát Chí K,
tên bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của sá bông K và tên bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của thị trận con quân,
sau khi thành lập thị trận chá Lan có sẽ tích tự nhiên là bá mề bá phể tà mề kí lơ mệt phong,
và quay mô dân số là mề bá nhìn bài chăm lý bốn người, tại vì anh sơn sẽ thành lập thị trận kìm nhăn,
trên các sử nhập tòa bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của thị trận anh sơn, sau khi thành lập thị trận kìm nhăn
có sẽ tích tự nhiên là bà vệ chín mi hai kilometh phong,
và quay mô dân số là chín miền chính chăm lý tà mề, tại vì anh tăng chương sẽ thành lập thị trận dung,
trên các sử nhập tòa bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của sát thành lĩnh,
tòa bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của sát thành đồng,
và tòa bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của thị trận thành chương, sau khi thành lập thị trận dung có sẽ tích tự nhiên là mề chính phẩy
tà mề lâm kì lối mết phong, pho quay mô dân số là hai li bà nhìn sấu trong bệ di hành người,
tại vì anh dễ châu sẽ thành lập thị trận dễ tành,
trên các sử nhập tòa bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của sát sĩnh tàn,
và tòa bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của thị trận dễ châu,
sau khi thành lập thị trận dễ tành có sẽ tích tự nhiên là bà vệ vì bà nhai kilomết phong,
pho quay mô dân số là hai li mốt miền sấu trong lý nằm người,
tại vì anh tàn sẽ tích lập thị trận hòa tành,
trên các sử nhập tòa bộ sẽ tích tự nhiên của sát sĩnh tích tự nhiên của thị trận dễ thành,
sau khi thành lập thị trận hòa tành của sĩnh tích tự nhiên là sảo vệ không chính kiến là mết phong,
pho quay mô dân số là mề mốt miền năm trong người.